in a previous video we have introduced
the idea of an aggregate production
function which is a fancy way for a
mathematical model that an economist
might use to tie the factors of
production in an economy to the actual
aggregate output of an economy the
aggregate output is why and then the
factors of production we've talked about
this before it's human capital it's
technology and it is regular capital or
non-human capital and so a is really
representing the technology factor here
and this term is often known as total
factor productivity
k is referring to the non-human capital
and of course capital starts with a c
but they use k for capital and then l
stands for the human capital you could
view it as standing for labor but
standing for a little bit more than that
and we'll talk about that in a second
and just to make this tangible because
it's written in function notation here
which might seem a little bit abstract
it's just saying hey some function of k
and l you could imagine an aggregate
production function that looks like this
where our aggregate output is equal to
our total factor productivity which is
once again a measure of our technology
times our capital to some power times
our human capital to some other power
and
in an introductory economics course you
wouldn't actually have to do this type
of computation taking things to
fractional exponents if although we have
many videos on khan academy explaining
how to take fractional exponents if you
are curious but this gives you a sense
that look if any one of these inputs
goes up well then you would expect
aggregate output to go up and if for
whatever reason these were to go down
then you would any one of these to go
down that that would have a negative
impact on aggregate output
but the focus of this video is really
thinking about if you were an economist
how would you actually come up with the
values for a k and l pause this video
and think about that so let's start with
l
which sometimes we imagine
represents labor but you really should
think of it as human capital how would
you measure human capital
well the most obvious thing is you could
measure labor
and how would you measure labor
well you could go and see well how many
people are in the labor force so measure
measure
the labor
force
and you might say well isn't that all
that there is to human capital but
remember not all labor is equivalent if
people are unhealthy they're not going
to be able to be
output as much if people aren't trained
they're not going to be able to output
as much so it's not just the quantity of
people in the labor force it's also
measures of education
that would factor into l so the more
educated a labor force the more trained
l would go up so higher people in labor
force l goes up more educated labor
force l goes up and a healthier labor
force
l would go up they're going to be able
to do more
now what about k
what about the capital stock of a
country
well you might be tempted to say well
maybe i could count the amount of
capital or something like that but that
wouldn't really make sense because there
could be some types of capital that
might be you know some just tools while
you might have another capital that's a
big building or a rail car or whatever
else and so the k
is actually measured by economists as
the value of the capital stock in a
country so let me write it this way
so the value
of capital
capital
in
your country or in the economy that we
care about
now a really interesting one is how do
you measure a
there isn't an obvious index for hey i
can just observe that and say that has
more technology than that other thing
and the way that economists often figure
out an a for an economy is by backing
into it
they can figure out an l and they can
figure out a k
and they know what the output they know
what the gdp of that country is the real
gdp
and then if different countries have the
same k and the same l but then their
gdps are different then that means that
they have a different a so the a you
could almost view as an adjustment to
fill in the gap to connect the dots
between the kl and the y but it would be
a measure of how technologically
advanced something is if my economy has
an a of 1 in order to make the numbers
work and your economy has an a of two
that means for some reason you're
getting twice the productivity given the
same capital and human capital as i am
which implies that you have twice the
technology